[Musique]
cap Noir cravate rayé lunettes rondes
les fans étaient au rendez-vous ce
samedi 4 février à l'occasion des nuits
Harry Potter c'est trop bien Harry
Potter on est des fans et bah le monde
il est magique le premier tome Harry
Potter à l'école des sorciers a soufflé
sa 25e bougie et pour fêter cet
événement Gallimard Jeunesse a mis à
contribution les librairies françaises
parmi les participants le pavé dans la
mare à Élancourt on a plusieurs
activités il va y avoir une chasse
l'espèce de chasse au trésor dans la
librairie des petits ateliers de
coloriage ou de coloriage ou de
fabrication et après sinon c'est des
petits jeux proposés par Gallimard des
mots mêlés ou autre sur l'unito sur
l'univers d'Harry Potter
[Musique]
le principe du jeu c'est de retrouver
sur cette banderole qui a derrière vous
tous les personnages qui sont numérotés
ici et retrouver leur nom les et les
écrire sur sur la feuille il faut
trouver la réponse
sur
l'énigme sur de vivre Harry Potter
contre qu'on doit trouver comme celui-là
là on a cette ningola
et au terme de cette soirée les moldion
ont été confrontés à un quiz les
gagnants ont pu remporter deux grands
livres pop-up du chemin de traverse le
pavé dans la mare étant lisse pour
participer à la grande finale du tournoi
des sorciers qui aura lieu en juin à
Paris
[Musique]